I'm a little bit sick today so I have a
scratchy throat so forgive me for that
but I think we'll we'll be able to
manage without it today I'm gonna talk a
little bit about writing up and
presenting your work but before I jump
into that I want to jump over to our
syllabus and orient us a little bit
we're actually going to cover three
topics today I'm gonna talk about
writing up and presenting your work but
we're also gonna have a couple of mini
lectures min and Jayadev are going to
talk about data augmentation and aquila
is going to talk about probing black box
models so we'll have those in the second
half of today's session also before we
get into that I want to make an
announcement Chris mentioned this on
Piazza he posted this on Piazza but just
in case anyone missed it I want to make
sure to draw attention to the era to
this we want you in your final paper at
the end of the paper to include a short
section that describes the authorship of
the paper so an authorship statement and
the idea is that this is a very concise
statement that just says who contributed
what to the final paper so this can be
very brief it could say for example
person a was mainly responsible for
gathering the data set person B was
mainly responsible for model
optimization person C was mainly
responsible for writing the paper or it
could say person a focused mainly on
this approach person be focused on that
approach and they're both presented in
the paper or it could say all of the
author's contributed equally to
collecting the data conducting the
experiments and writing the paper it's
really up to you it should be a truthful
reflection of the relative contributions
of the respective authors and the
motivation for this is that we think
that this is just scientific good
practice in fact it's one that we'd like
to see become more and more a part of
the norms of the research community P
Nez is already using this and there's a
link here to
guidance that's given to the two penis
authors that's the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Science and we're
hopeful that this will become more and
more widespread in more and more venues
for example in in ACL which is the the
dominant NLP conference we do not intend
or expect to use this information in
assigning grades our expectation is that
the team members who are collaborating
together will all receive the same grade
we reserve the right to make
distinctions and not to assign the same
grade to all members of a team but we'll
do that only in the most unusual cases
and we wouldn't do that without
discussing it first with the people
involved in the project any questions
about that yeah can just be one line
that says I'm the sole author and I am
responsible for everything
I think we're solo project it's it's a
moot point
I suppose it's to just to meet the
formal requirements a single sentence is
is still appropriate but it doesn't need
to say very much any other questions
about the final project before we go on
note that today's class session is the
last regular class session next week we
encourage you to schedule time to meet
with your mentors for the project to
talk about your progress on the project
but this this class will be the last
regularly scheduled session yes you
think this is a good practice in order
to spread um it was kind of confused by
this practice I have loyalty papers and
I was wondering why you think it's a
good practice my philosophy and this
will be an interesting question to ask
response as well but my philosophy on
this is that it's about responsibility
and accountability that it's about
making it clear who's accountable for
which parts of the paper I think it's um
likely in this class but there are
exceptional situations where
accountability winds up really mattering
for example if there are problems with a
paper if there if concern arises that
like some results were falsified or
something like that you want to know
who's responsible for that and so I
think the authorship statement amounts
to the authors making it clear I am
responsible for this part of the work
and I stand behind this part of the work
okay
so let me switch into the topic of
writing up and present in your work and
I think first I want to say a little bit
about why we're talking about this to me
this topic this is a little bit unusual
because this is not a technical topic
this is about how to communicate the
results of your work and it's about
finding a way to communicate the results
of your work clearly and convincingly
and in a way that's going to have impact
yes thank you
why it does that maybe if I just do this
it won't do that communicating your work
both in written form and in spoken form
so in an oral presentation I think this
I think this topic is unfortunately one
that sometimes is undervalued by
scientists and engineers
I think there's sometimes an unfortunate
tendency to think that great work will
speak for itself and that it doesn't
matter that much how you present it and
I have to forcefully disagree with the
idea that great work will always speak
for itself actually something happened
this week that kind of sharpened this
for me
murray gell-mann died on friday murray
gell-mann is
great physicist you've probably heard
his name he's responsible for inventing
the quark and introducing the theory
that hadrons are made up out of quarks
in 1964 when I was reading the biography
or the what's the word obituary thank
you of Murray gell-mann
one of the the obituaries I was reading
pointed out that there is another guy
George swag who the same year
independently arrived at the theory of
quarks I had never heard of George swag
before I don't know it do you guys know
this name I had never heard of his name
I certainly had heard of Murray Gelman
well maybe part of the reason this is
something that I learned from reading
those obituaries swag named his concept
aces and Gelman named his kind of the
concept at he came up with quarks and
quarks somehow was a much more memorable
name it was a sticky name it was good
marketing it was good marketing for his
ideas and so everybody knows who Gelman
is a lot of people don't know who swag
is I didn't know who he was there may be
lots of other reasons right they had
these guys had long careers they did
lots of other stuff Gelman is
responsible for tons of other advances
in physics so I'm not saying this is the
only reason why Gelman is well-known but
it doesn't hurt that he found a way to
market his ideas in a very effective way
I think a lot of times as scientists and
engineers we tend to think of marketing
as a bit icky like respectable people
you know don't soil the soil their hands
with with marketing and thinking about
how to present their ideas but it really
does make a difference and it would be a
terrible shame if you invested a huge
amount of work in collecting data in
staying up late at night running
experiments and being very innovative in
your ideas and in your thinking but then
didn't follow through on
by finding a way to communicate your
ideas in a way that will have a lasting
impact on the community and it will let
others benefit from your learning and
your hard work so that's really what I
want to focus on today and our hope is
that by spending a little bit of time
talking about this topic that this is
one of the unique benefits of this class
that this class can be a very practical
introduction not only to natural
language understanding but in how to be
an effective researcher and part of
being an effective researcher is
communicating your work in a way that's
going to have impact we also want to
inspire you to think bigger than just
this class of course your immediate goal
is to finish your final project make a
video presentation which I'll say a
little bit more about at the end and
write a final paper but you can aim
higher than that as well the work that
you're doing right now could lead to
insights and ideas that wind up having
lasting influence I think Chris
mentioned that there was a student in I
forget what there was last year or two
years ago had this insight about the
hypothesis only baseline for natural
language inference specifically for the
NL s nli data set and that was a pretty
impactful insight that showed the
community something really meaningful
about this task or at least about that
data set that so many people had been
optimizing on on on the SN Li
leaderboard so it really is possible for
class projects to wind up having a
larger impact on the research community
and there have been many papers from
this class over the last several years
that have been turned into conference
papers and thereby how to had a broader
reach another reason to think about the
topics that we're looking at today is
that oftentimes the next step in your
career will involve presenting your
research to others this is certainly
true if you want to go on to an academic
career but it's even true for many
positions in industry certainly any
research oriented position in industry
commonly as part of the interview
process they'll invite you to give a
research talk where you go and at Google
or at Apple or even at a startup talk
about some research project that you've
you've been involved in and so finding a
way to communicate that effectively not
only helps to disseminate your research
but also helps to build your credibility
and open doors for you so today I'm
going to talk about four different
topics we'll talk about how to write a
research paper specifically an NLP
research paper I'll talk a little bit
about the conference submission process
just so that you have sort of an
overview of how papers wind up getting
accepted to conferences I'll give you
some advice on oral presentations and
then I'll give you some very tactical
tips on the video presentations that
we're looking for for this class here's
a New Yorker cartoon about writing
papers sometimes it feels like this
okay so here's an outline of a typical
NLP paper there's the the field of NLP
has evolved some conventions about how
papers are typically structured and this
kind of gives you it gives you a sense
of what those conventions are and so
when you see papers that are presented
at ACL or emn LP or Knakal or ACL they
tend to follow these conventions I'll
say more in a few minutes about what the
conventions are but first I want to talk
about why these conventions and there's
really two reasons
why it's a good idea to follow these
conventions one is that the conventions
have evolved for a reason the community
has the research community has converged
on these conventions because they're
effective because they're an effective
way to communicate your ideas and I'll
explain more why in a moment the other
reason to follow convened
is that because they're conventions they
make it easy for your audience to
understand what they're reading they
make it easy to Drock
typically the content of your papers
will be technically dense your audience
will already have a challenge
understanding the technical content you
don't want to double that challenge by
making them also struggle to understand
the rhetorical structure that you're
trying to follow if you follow
established conventions that won't be an
issue they'll know what to expect why
they're reading what they're reading and
it will make it easier for them to
understand your paper so the the
structure typically looks like this I'm
not going to dwell here because the next
slide is somewhat redundant with this
but I'll just say this is kind of a
conventional ordering of sections of an
NLP research paper you do have the
freedom to play with this to violate
conventions but if you're gonna violate
the conventions you should do it very
consciously and you should do it for a
good reason not just sort of haphazardly
and the reason this is shown with eight
pages and that's because typically NLP
conference papers are eight pages with
two columns single spaced there's part
of the convention is a convention for
laying out and formatting which you will
follow in your final papers for this
class so this is somewhat redundant with
the previous slide it's just sort of a
different way of presenting it what
should go into a paper yeah this is very
for single against that I don't have a
great answer for you on this that one
might be a somewhat arbitrary convention
I think some of the conventions are very
well motivated there's good reasons for
them maybe some of them are arbitrary
and that one might be an arbitrary one
but here's what's a lot less arbitrary I
think a great paper should have a
narrative arc and the arc needs to
include these elements what is the
problem that you are trying to solve why
is this problem important why should we
care about it
what have others done in this problem
what approaches have others explored and
why are those approaches not fully
satisfactory why is there still room to
do something more that's those three
things are kind of the introduction to
your paper that's kind of the preamble
it launches you into your story then you
need to talk about what's new what are
you doing and this is really the meat of
your story what is the approach that
you're gonna follow what is the model
that you're gonna develop
what distinguishes that from other
things that have been done before and
this is probably the longest part and
the most technically dense part of your
paper and sometimes it will include a
description of data set if if you're if
the data set that you're working way
there's not completely standard
something that lots of other people have
worked on if it's something new if you
collected data you need to explain how
you did that then you need to talk about
how you're going to evaluate the success
of what you did then you need to talk
about the evaluation itself the results
of the evaluation then some discussion
of the significance of those results so
what does it mean what can we learn what
are the strengths what are the
limitations of the approach that you
took and then perhaps finally some
pointers to future work so almost
assuredly the work that you've done is
not complete it's not the last word
there are probably still limitations in
whatever you did and if you can
highlight what those limitations are and
point to opportunities for future work
you're doing the community
service by helping them identify what
the next steps are for further progress
in this field so those are kind of the
key elements of the story that you want
to tell I did that off the top of my
head but hopefully it aligns really well
I think it does align really well with
what's here because it's all theirs
it's all there's a reason for all of
these pieces you kind of need all of
these pieces in order to have a complete
story what are you working on why does
it matter what have others done
what are you doing how are you going to
evaluate it what was the result of that
that evaluation and what does it all
mean that's a complete story of your
work later I'm gonna talk about how to
write a good abstract and also how to
give a good talk and I'm gonna kind of
repeat what I just said because no
matter what format you're telling your
story in it might be written or spoken
it might be 8 pages long or it might be
a single paragraph but you kind of want
to have those key elements Stewart
Cheever is yes I've seen both approaches
one is like and the other approach being
you first describe you like the overview
of the model and then go into depth so I
mean what what is it that dictates how
you would write that particular part
down like in some papers you first
describe how you did feature engineering
and then again what was the classified I
think there's room for variation here
and room for personal preference I think
my inclination would be to sort of do a
two pass approach first a top down and
then a bottom up so first start with a
high level and say here's the overall
picture of the system then dive into
individual pieces and describe the
individual pieces but the
come back up to the top level and say
how all those pieces come together but I
think there the there's less of a
community convention or a prescriptive
answer on how to answer that question I
think there's a little bit more room for
variation so Stuart Schieber is an NLP
professor and researcher at Harvard and
he has this document which we have a
link to here which is about writing
great papers and he talks about the
rational reconstruction format he
describes there's actually kind of a
Hegelian what's the word dialectic thank
you there's a Hegelian dialectic here
with a thesis and antithesis and
synthesis okay
so we start with the continental style
he describes the continental style as
one that's extremely concise and opaque
and just kind of lays the answer out but
doesn't really tell you how it got there
when I read this I am reminded of John
Nash John Nash's PhD thesis was 26 pages
long my PhD thesis was 120 pages long
that's because I'm not as smart as John
Nash by the way John Nash had two
citations in his PhD thesis if you're
John Nash you don't cite other people
other people cite you my PhD thesis had
like 150 citations because I'm not John
Nash if you're John Nash you can get
away with this if you're just about
anybody else it's not recommended this
is not the best way to communicate your
ideas and how you got to them and make
them understandable to others it's too
cryptic it's too dense and doesn't
provide a way in the antithesis the
historical style so this is where this
is kind of a narrative of your research
process you describe the whole research
process in laborious detail and it's
kind of like
you start out it was a dark and stormy
night when I began to investigate the
problem of natural language inference
and you go on from there right and
describe all the things that didn't work
again all the places where he got stuck
this has the benefit of being more
understandable than the continental
style but it's going to be long-winded
and include lots of information that
doesn't actually help anybody and it's
also not really the recommended approach
and really the ideal approach is what
Stewart's Eber calls the rational
reconstruction approach so in the
rational reconstruction approach you lay
out the problem in a way that makes the
the approach that you arrive at seem
almost inevitable makes it seem like a
logical and natural consequence of the
constraints of the problem and makes the
the the whole approach and what you did
and why you did it seemed very
straightforward as as Stewart super says
convince the reader that your solution
is trivial and fortunately the
conventions of the community these these
conventions this kind of conventional
narrative arc that I described part of
the reason for these conventions is that
they naturally bring you toward this
rational reconstruction style this is
not a narrative and it's also not unknow
Paik John Nash style PhD thesis it's an
explanation of a way of approaching a
problem that makes sense and that's
driven by the motivations and the
constraints of the problem some hints on
mathematic intime x' you'll have
formulas or other mathematical notation
in your paper David Goss has some good
hints on how to do that effectively okay
let me spend a couple minutes talking
about conferences but first an xkcd
cartoon this is one of my favorite this
is an old xkcd cartoon this is number 5
41 if you're a regular xkcd reader you
know that these are numbered
sequentially and I think we're up to
like 1700 now or something like that so
this is an old one but this is one of my
favorites because it's about how to put
Smiley's inside parentheses and I
struggle with this don't you struggle
with this we all struggle with this and
I think he's the first guy who you know
point out that we all struggle with this
I also like this because he starts off
by saying hi I'm Randall welcome to my
TED talk and welcome to my TED talk is
kind of a meme now but as far as I know
he's the first person who like used it
in this way to be funny so I love this
cartoon okay so I want to talk a little
bit about what it's like to submit a
paper to an NLP conference and what the
review process is like and how your
paper actually gets accepted because
this is information that you'll need to
know if you actually submit a paper to
an NLP conference I'm by the way I'm
sure there are other people in the room
from the teaching team and maybe others
as well who have been through this
process and I hope you'll speak up and
help fill in the gap whatever gaps I
leave or share your own insights on this
process so here's a kind of an overview
of the typical process for getting a
paper accepted first you write the paper
you guys are doing that now
so that's great and then you submit the
paper through there's a usually a web
interface where you upload your PDF and
as part of the submission process they
give you a bunch of key words that you
can choose from and the key words will
be things like machine translation or
computational semantics or natural
language inference they sort of
correspond to subfields of NLP they may
correspond to specific techniques like
reinforcement learning they may be
things like you know human annotation or
something like that
techniques strategies topic subtopics of
NLP that are particularly salient for
your paper so hundreds of people upload
lots and lots of titles the reviewers
actually the organizers the conference
chair
oh yeah conference typically has several
different areas the areas each will have
area chairs and the chairs are
responsible for recruiting reviewers to
help review papers in that area and
they'll organize the papers into areas
in large part based on the keywords and
then they'll send or they'll put on a
web page lists of the submitted papers
and invite all the reviewers to come
look at the list of papers and submit
bids on which ones they want to be
responsible for reviewing so as a
reviewer you'll see this webpage with a
hundred papers on it you'll see the
titles you'll be able to click through
to get the abstract of the paper what
you won't see is author names or
affiliations or anything like that you
will see the keywords that are on the
paper and based on that you need to
choose which papers you want to review
and so naturally you'll your decision on
which papers to bid on will be largely
influenced by the titles that you're
seeing which is a good reminder that
choosing a good title for your paper
really helps good titles help to attract
attention and get people interested in
your paper there like an advertisement
for your paper
the ideal title is one that gives a very
clear indication of what's going to be
in the paper but in a way that makes it
interesting and enticing here's a bad
title that is from Maya this is a title
that I used from my own experience it
was actually not a title of a paper but
it was a title of a talk that I gave one
time and the title was two aspects of
the problem of natural language
inference
that's a terrible title it tells you
that it's about natural language
inference okay but two aspects of the
problem okay but which two aspects and
what are they why should I care
we have no idea there's nothing there's
nothing interests me
actually now that I think about it it's
kind of like those listicles on the web
that are like seven things you should do
to enhance your whatever not a great
model to follow them a much better
example of a touch one of my favorite
titles of a recent it's not NLP but a
machine learning paper at nips in 2016
there was a paper that was titled
learning to learn by gradient descent by
gradient descent maybe some of this was
from deep mind maybe some of you read
this paper this paper and what I love
about this title is that it's really
descriptive you know what's gonna be in
that paper it's gonna be about learning
to optimize the gradient descent process
itself so you know what the con you know
what the papers about and you know what
you're gonna learn from this paper and
you know whether you're gonna be
interested in this paper but then the
title is also a little bit whimsical
because it has this recursive structure
and nerds love recursion and probably
you can't get away with making every
title into a recursive title like that
but if you have a title that's both very
descriptive of what it's about and also
somehow intriguing or with a twist or
something appealing about it that's a
great way to attract attention okay so
so although reviewers submit all their
bids on which papers they want to review
the program chairs then assign reviewers
based on their bids the reviewers
actually read the papers write comments
and supply ratings and I'll tell you a
lot more about the ratings in just a
moment then there's a response period so
the authors are allowed to respond to
the reviews so the reviews the comments
from the reviews are sent back to the
authors not the ratings the actually not
sure the ratings - okay so the authors
will see the ratings and they'll see the
comments that the reviewers have
supplied and they have the opportunity
to respond to
those comments for some short period of
time and this can stimulate some
discussion amongst the reviewers and
this is the first time typically that
the reviewers are no longer anonymous to
each other so there may be three
different reviewers who have read a
particular paper up until this point
they're anonymous to each other but now
their identities are revealed the
authors of the paper are still anonymous
and we don't know who they are but the
reviewers become known to each other and
you can have some interesting discussion
around the paper and finally the program
committee does some magic to figure out
which papers get in to the conference
and which ones don't
probably largely based on the scores
that have been assigned so let's talk a
little bit more now about the scores
this is when reviewers are asked to
assign scores for papers they're asked
to evaluate on many different dimensions
this is a list that's typically used for
a CL and I think other NLP conferences
have lists that are like this but with
minor variation so let's let me talk a
little bit about each of these
appropriateness basically means is this
per is this paper a good fit for this
conference does it sort of fit within
the theme and the topics that are
appropriate for this conference might be
a great paper that doesn't belong in
this conference and so it might get a
low score for appropriateness clarity I
think is pretty self-explanatory can you
understand what the people actually did
in this in this investigation replicate
replicability is a criterion that's
growing in importance I think five or
ten years ago people didn't really think
about this that much more and more it's
becoming part of a community standard
that results should be replicable this
is really healthy and a big part of
replica replicability is making code and
data available online so that others can
go and repeat the experiment and see if
they get the same results originality I
think is pretty self-explanatory
soundness and correctness were the
decisions
well well motivated decisions is are the
things that I try were the things that I
tried the right things to try do my the
sort of logical steps that I followed in
my investigation makes sense meaningful
comparison did I include comparisons to
all of the work that I should have
compared to or is there work out there
that's very relevant but I seem to be
unaware of it if I'm unaware of related
work or if in my quantitative results I
don't make comparisons to closely
related work
that's a Mis thoroughness did I did I
explain everything I need to explain
sometimes a lack of thoroughness can
impair replicability if I haven't
actually specified all of the details of
all of the steps it makes it hard to
replicate my results impact of ideas or
results I think that's pretty
self-explanatory impact of resources
this is particularly relevant if your
work introduces a new data set to the
community that might be of use to others
not introducing a new data set is not a
problem it doesn't mean that there's
anything wrong but if you have
introduced a new data set that's going
to be valuable to the community that can
really help to increase the the impact
and the appeal of your work and finally
the overall recommendation which is
undoubtedly the most important score
it's sort sort of a intended to be a
distillation of all the others so all of
the other scores should inform the
overall evaluation those are the scores
and then typically they ask for a couple
of other bits of metadata they ask do
you write as a reviewer do you recommend
this work be presented as a poster in a
poster session or as an oral
presentation so as a talk it's
definitely more prestigious to be
selected for an oral presentation than a
poster but on the other hand there's
nothing wrong with presenting your work
as
and it's a great way to get exposure for
your work and sometimes presenting your
work as a poster is actually appealing
because it facilitates discussion with
your audience what sort of one-on-one
discussion makes it very easy for
interested people to ask questions
sometimes by the way some conferences
have both short and long oral
presentations so a long oral
presentation is typically a 20-minute
presentation sometimes there are also
short oral presentations which are like
five minutes or seven minutes of course
as an author you'd rather have a
long-form presentation than a short form
presentation but they'll often ask that
here and they may ask whether this paper
should be considered as a candidate for
best paper typically a conference will
have at least one best paper award
sometimes they'll have like best paper
overall and best best student paper or
something like that oh and some
conferences have both long-form papers
which are the eight pages the the a page
convention that we looked at before and
also short form papers which are four
pages you may have submitted a paper as
an eight page paper but a reviewer might
have an opportunity to say actually I
think this one would be better as a
short paper if it were reworked a little
bit and typically the bar is a little
bit lower for short papers reviewers and
it will be the the program chairs will
make the final determination on the best
paper award but reviewers have the
opportunity to effectively nominate a
paper - for consideration as a best
paper
and the unbe best paper award still
because his comfort is value that's
something that even program chairs in
the Canadians have to hit together
making the codebase
open-source and that making your data
visible even the codebase maybe you set
the random seeds and so on so forth but
beyond that within the code structure in
itself what are the things that you
think make think research reproducible I
think first and foremost just making the
code available which 10 years ago
unfortunately was not the norm or 20
years ago was not the norm these days to
put all the code on github and I think
just putting the code on github is a
huge proportion of what you need to do
to make the code reproducible now of
course adopting good software
engineering practices and making sure
that the code is readable and documented
and not a massive spaghetti that nobody
could you know possibly understand helps
as well but making it available is by
far the most important thing a slide
with the names of some notable NLP
conferences I won't talk about each of
these but these are kind of the biggest
and most reputable NLP conferences some
additional conferences these conferences
tend to be a little bit more more
focused on the web and information
retrieval rather than NLP and these
conferences are a little bit more
focused on machine learning and include
lots of other topics beyond NLP like
vision for example but NLP tends to be
an important sort of sub current or sub
theme in those conferences as well so if
you're thinking about trying to to bring
a paper to a conference these are kind
of the likeliest suspect
to look at I won't talk about this
because I'm not knowledgeable about this
the abstract of your paper is a little
paragraph that summarizes your paper and
the best way to think about it is that
it's an advertisement for your paper
people will read the abstract to decide
whether they want to make the investment
in reading the eight-page paper
sometimes reviewers will read it to
decide on whether to bid on to bid to
review your paper and so just like with
the title you want the abstract to be
both informative and engaging and you
kind of want this most of the same key
elements that I described before you
want to say what problem you're working
on you may not have enough room in the
abstract to say why it's an important
problem or what previous approaches have
been employed but you definitely want to
say what your contribution is and you
want to communicate the most important
result of an evaluation in your abstract
and why it's significant really the
abstract should summarize what are the
key contributions of your paper and why
should i as a reader be interested in
learning more and you have to find a way
to do this in only about 100 words
abstracts are very concise and they
should be polished like a like a like a
gem it's really valuable to get feedback
from other people on your abstracts on
whether they are clear and whether
there's any way to pack more into a very
tight space okay a little bit of advice
on giving talks actually I have nothing
new to say here this is kind of exactly
what I said about writing a paper the
format is different but the content is
going to be largely similar to what I
said for writing a paper
Jeff Pullum has some great guidance for
giving talks that I encourage you to go
read this is a very short
document where he gives some great rules
the one that I want to emphasize here is
number five remember that you're an
advocate not the defendant so kind of a
metaphor from law right you're when you
present your work orally it's not you
that's on trial it's some ideas that are
on trial it's some some work an
investigation an approach a model don't
take it personally don't get wrapped up
up it we don't get wrapped up in it and
if people question it don't take that as
an attack on you don't let your ego be
part of it it's okay if the work is
incomplete it's okay if the work has
flaws be forthright about that be
dispassionate in your presentation of it
do your best to present the work in its
best light but don't take anything about
it personally and that really helps to
make the presentation convincing and
effective and it kind of echoes this
insight from from Patrick Blackburn he
says where the good talks come from from
honesty be honest about the work that
you've done as long as you're honest you
kind of can't go wrong in presenting the
work a little bit about slides and
different styles of creating slides
there's kind of two very different
approaches to creating slides one is the
minimalist approach the other is the
maximalist approach the minimalist
approach is to have very little on each
slide maybe just a couple of words the
slides go very quickly you kind of blaze
through them you're like click click
click click quick as you talk if you
were to look at the slides in isolation
if somebody just gave you the deck but
you didn't see the oral presentation
they might be hard to understand because
there's just a couple of words or maybe
a diagram or something on each slide
but there they tend to be more exciting
and interesting as oral presentations
the maximalist approach by the way this
slide is more like the maximalist
approach the maximalist approach has
lots of words on the slide they tend to
go slower as you go through them but if
you look at them in isolation they're a
lot easier to understand because all of
the words or most of the words that you
need are there on the slide a
shortcoming of the maximalist approach
is that the audience is torn between
reading the slide and listening to you
and if you have a lot of words on the
slide when the slide first comes up
they're probably reading the slide and
they're probably not listening to you so
there are pros and cons to these two
different approaches I'm preparing to
speak at WWDC next week and if you know
anything about Apple
you know the Apple takes the minimalist
approach we have slides that have like
one word on them and they go at a pace
of like one slide every five seconds or
something like that and then there's
like graphics and you know it's a very
different style there's no right answer
here you need to find a style that works
for you and works for the content that
you're trying to present but I think
it's it's valuable to think about the
pros and cons of these different styles
Edward Tufte and Peter Norvig have
thoughts about PowerPoint those thoughts
are not flattering but if but this is
kind of amusing if you want to go click
on these links later more mundane things
I won't talk about all these but there's
a bunch of really good advice here it's
really good to test your setup in
advance
typically when you're presenting at a
conference there will be like five talks
in a row before that there will be a
break if you're presenting during that
block test you're set up in the break
before that block I one time didn't do
that made that mistake and I spent I had
20 minutes for my talk and I spent the
first five minutes of my talk fumbling
with my setup standing in front of a
room of 300 people like fumbling with my
setup and it was incredibly embarrassing
and then when I
finally did get started with my talk I
was all flustered and my talk was a
disaster so learn from my mistake test
your setup before you launch into your
talk also make sure you don't have any
windows in the background with
embarrassing stuff on it I have not made
that mistake but I've seen other people
who have made that mistake and the
question period typically when you give
a talk at a conference there will be a
each talk is 20 minutes and then there's
usually 5 minutes for questions the
question period is really important
because this is when you get feedback
from the audience about what they want
to know more about questions are great
if you get questions in your question
period especially thoughtful questions
that's a sign that you've really
connected with your audience and they're
interested in your topic if you don't
get any questions you should be a little
bit bummed out that somehow you failed
to get your audience interested in your
topic but questions are also scary
because you have no idea what's gonna
come at you the talk you can rehearse
and rehearse and rehearse and feel
really well prepared the questions there
is no way to prepare you just have to
think on your feet and do your best
you'll do better if you really know your
topic well which you will but even so
you have no idea what's gonna come at
you sometimes questions will come that
you don't know how to respond to that's
okay it's okay to say I don't know but I
would love to talk to you more about
this afterward and actually that can be
a great opportunity to make a new
connection with somebody in the research
community that can lead to anything it
could lead to a future collaboration so
treat that as an opportunity and as a
welcome thing okay
a couple tactical things about your
presentations for this class you're
gonna prepare a video presentation it's
due on June 5th that's coming up soon
it's gonna be a four minute talk you're
gonna create a short deck in Google
slides or PowerPoint or keynote you're
gonna record yourself talking through
this deck you can do that on a Mac using
QuickTime or if you're not on a Mac
you'll have to figure it out
but maybe other people in the class will
have helpful suggestions for you you'll
upload the video to YouTube you can make
a private if you want to and then you'll
send us the link for this four-minute
video you don't have to be in the video
your your face doesn't have to be in the
video the video will just show your
slides audio will be you talking through
the deck because I mean it takes me like
one and a half to two hours and it's
pretty intense
I don't have any specific strategy to
suggest but I share your experience like
I can't absorb an 8 page dense paper in
one sitting typically so if it's a paper
that I mean sometimes I'll if the paper
that I don't think it's that important
for me to really get I'll sort of like
read the abstract and introduction
carefully and then kind of skim the rest
but if it's a paper that I really want
to get I typically need to read it in
more than one sitting in order to fully
absorb it beyond that I don't have any
specific strategy to recommend I think
that's ok it's not what people usually
do but I think it's ok yeah
okay I'm gonna hand off at this point 2
min and Jaya dev all right so I'm gonna
be giving a short presentation on data
augmentation for natural language
processing so on what is data
augmentation so they documentation is a
technique to arm to increase the amount
of relevant data and in machine learning
and especially in deep learning more
data usually means better accuracy so if
you don't really have a lot of training
examples we can't write a documentation
techniques to your arm to create or
synthetic on training examples the
documentation is actually very popular
in computer vision people create new
images by shifting the original images
or creating a zoomed in or zoomed out
versions rotating lifting and etc so how
do we do such transformation in natural
language sure we can flip a sentence or
our rotate a sentence so we need to come
up with our different approaches so
before we actually talk about the actual
data argumentation on techniques we ran
on some simple experiments so we wanted
to do on sentiment classification of
IMDB movie reviews using ODC regression
and we wanted to see the correlation
between number of unpossible number of
training examples and the model test
actress as you can see if we only have a
thousand training examples although our
model accuracy was only about 79% but
with more training examples arm they
actually see arm increased significantly
so it's usually the case that the small
number with small number of training
examples arm you can really have a
really high performance model so in
those situations they documentation can
really help boost the performance so for
this presentation I'm going to assume
that we only have 1000 examples we're
gonna apply different de documentation
techniques to see if we can boost the
the accuracy of 79% built with your own
ask any questions so how do we actually
argument extra language training data so
we're gonna be discussing on two main
approaches the first one is easy their
documentation on EDA which uses on very
simple heuristics to your arm to
transport sentences to create arm new
relevant examples and we're also going
to talk about back translation which
uses on your own machine translation to
to give noise to your
sentences so as we mentioned before arm
the baseline is gonna be the IMDB
thousand examples trained logistic
regression model which has an accuracy
about seventy nine percent and we're
going to apply arm EDA and back
translation to arm to argument beyond
the training samples okay so arm we're
gonna look at the sentence the final
project is the main assignment of course
to explore our different a documentation
models we're gonna transform this
sentence using back translation and EDA
to give you on some sense of how that is
it can be transformed so let's first
talk about easy data augmentation um
it's a paper written by way and job in
2019 so it's a relatively new research
paper and I'm it uses on or very simple
techniques arm first it uses synonym
replacement so it randomly selects n
words from a sentence and it replaced
replaces those words with its synonyms
with their synonyms random insertion is
something very similar but instead of
replacing it strong the synonyms and
random swap and random deletion or
priest of expiratory arm random swapped
swaps to random words and random
deletion arm deletes a random word so
let's look at our example sentence the
final project is the main assignment of
the course so if we apply a synonym
replacement we can replace main with
principal because our principal is a
synonym of main so the resulting
sentence can be on the final project is
the principal assignment of the course
if we apply random insertion we can
insert last because last say the synonym
of final and the resulting sentence now
becomes the final project is the main
assignment of all last the course which
doesn't make a lot of sense as a
sentence it's still roughly on retains
original meaning and if we perform
random swap we can swap main with
assignment and we can also delete a
random word by using random deletion and
in this case on the word project is
deleted so if you look at all these
sentences you can see that it doesn't
necessarily preserve the original
meanings but they're roughly are similar
and in line with the
sentence so the authors of the EDA paper
actually ran late in space visualization
of the argument the sentences and the
original stand consistent as you can see
the red box roughly coincide with the
red circles and the blue dots also
roughly coincide with the blue triangles
meaning that arm they roughly have
similar meanings so EDA can be very
useful in simplifying new sentences that
are relevant to our training examples so
we apply EDA to our thousand training
example dataset and we used the github
repository that was published and
released by the young EDA authors it's
relatively simple to set up and it
doesn't it's relatively easy to arm to
perform the operation using the
repository so we created 10,000 more EDA
argumented examples and then we use
those examples in addition to the
original examples into our logistic
regression model and you're able to see
about 1.2 percent of accuracy
improvement which is always pretty arm
significant because um EDA nearly
performs very simple heuristics ok so
let's talk about back translation so
back translation uses on neural machine
translation to argument training data so
more simply put when you have an English
sentence you translate that into an
intermediate language such as German
French or anything can think of and then
you translate back turns like that back
into English and the resulting sentence
is gonna be kind of a paraphrased
version of the original sentence there's
gonna be some noise into the sentence so
let's take a look at an example so this
is an example of using a google
translator so i'm our sentence um the
final project is the main assignment
took of the course if we translate that
into german and french lay back into
english the resulting sentence now
becomes the final project is the main
task of the course as you can see the
assignment is swapped with tasks so it's
kind of kind of like a paraphrase
version of the original sentence we can
use different intermediate language as I
try Korean if we if we translate to
Korean and back into English the
sentence now becomes the final project
is a major challenge for
course which is a bit of a more a
paraphrased version so I'm using rules
translator arm we discovered that it's
possible to create paraphrased versions
of sentence arm using back translation
so we applied back translation to our
thousand examples so we use on Google
Translate API to translate from English
to German and German back to English and
we created ten we created a thousand arm
back translating examples so when we
combined those back translating examples
to our original training data and used
it to train our lugisu regression model
we were able to see a pre impressive on
1.8 percent accuracy improvement so
lastly arm we also used back translation
in addition to EDA to see arm how things
are gonna work up and we trained our
logistic regression model on the
thousand arm original training examples
and ten thousand argumented examples
from EDA and also a thousand documented
examples from back translation and then
when we combine all of them and then
when we train a logistic regression
model we're able to get an accuracy of
over around 81 percent which is about
two percent increase from the baseline
model so these are some few data
argumentation techniques we can probably
use they're relatively simple to
implement for the back translation you
just have to set up a Google Translate
API and just call it from from your code
and if you're working on your final
project and if you don't have a lot of
data and you think that having more data
is gonna help to boost your models
performance I recommend looking into our
data augmentation techniques including
EDA or vectorization even if you do have
a lot of data I think it's still worth
Dom experimenting to see how things go
and you can always write down the
results so I'm on your final paper or
your final project even if it doesn't
work out cool that's
techniques like that might give the
gains or is it always kind of like just
a little bit so from the papers that I
read it seems that they documentation is
still relatively new and natural image
processing so long I couldn't we find
anymore on comprehensive or complicated
patient but these are most widely used
augmentation techniques hi everyone I'm
Michaela I'll be talking about proving
that more black box models today so
essentially this the whole concept of
probing is to be able to understand what
models are actually doing it's some sort
of introspection technique today we'll
be talking specifically with regard to
like contextualize word when word
embeddings and sentence and buildings
but this is something which can be
applied to a lot of other models as well
like like I'm sure everyone's heard
about the open I GP T is like huge
language model it's it produces these
contextualize word embeddings which is
trained on a simple objective of
language modeling but they do encode a
lot of other information and it's really
interesting to see how they encode this
information and how it can be
effectively applied to a lot more
downstream tasks so informal definition
of what a probing task is that it's a
classification problem which focuses on
some simple linguistic properties of
this embeddings this is an informal
definition from this paper which by
Facebook AI research I would highly
recommend reading this paper if you want
to more into like how probing
architectures work and that sort of
stuff
and so these flowing methods are
designed to evaluate to what extent like
they they encode the sort of linguistic
properties
so when you say probing tasks most of
these probing tasks are going to be very
simple so that you don't have like
interfering results you're going to be
probing for something very specific and
these probing architectures are really
simple in the sense that they would be
like a linear transformation or like a
two layer MLP essentially the main idea
is when you do have these sort of
embedding representations you want to
understand what sort of information they
encode rather than forcing some sort of
classifier to learn this on its behalf
and it's easier to control for biases in
these proventil since it's simple
because you can't really control this in
like the downstream does and this is
going to be an architecture which is
agnostic of where you get this embedding
representation from which makes it
really useful in my opinion because it's
very pluggable and one sort of probing
task which is designed to you know probe
for certain properties can be applied to
different models so one example is given
that you have a pre-trained encoder
which is strained on some objective you
want to get some one vector
representation from this encoder and
then you would be passing that to
through your probing model and as I
already mentioned that this probing
model is designed to be like really
shallow like it's going to be like a one
layer transformation or a two layer and
then you at the end of this it would be
a classification task based on what sort
of linguistic properties you are trying
to see is encoded in this sort of word
representation so today we'll be talking
about two sorts of probes one is like
sentence embedding probes and the other
one is word and breeding probes they
both go hand-in-hand but I kind of want
to highlight some of the characteristics
which you can actually probe for when
you're looking at a sentence level
versus like a word level so given a
sentence level and building you could
you I've just named two of them but you
can obtain like a sentence level I'm
building from a biased a.m. or a gated
cognate or any other encoder which is
trained on
any objective like it can be machine
translation it can be Essen Ally it can
be skipped odd skipped art is a special
kind where you're training this encoder
such that neighboring sentences have a
more similar or there's a lot of
literature on how encoders initialize
with random weights they can also encode
properties of the sentence of your word
so given that you do get an embedding at
the like when you do pass a sentence
through this encoder and you get an
embedding at the end of it the couple of
properties you can probe for like
surface level information when I say
surface level information it can be like
does this embedding have some sort of
information about what the actual length
of the sentence was word content like
can you actually get information about
what sort of words are in the sentence
syntactic information is whether this is
more on an encoded level whether you try
to understand whether this encoder is
actually sensitive to some syntax like
semantic information like when I say by
Gram shift given a sentence if I swap
two Biograph like if I take a bigram and
I swap that and I pass it through my
encoder is my encoder going to be
sensitive to the swap or not and then
semantics is for example is tense you
can find the tens of the the main Clause
verb I actually like the last s which is
the semantic odd-man-out task where
basically what you do is you're going to
replace a a noun or a verb randomly with
another noun or a verb but the unigram
frequency of this particular noun or
verb which is swapped out is similar to
the original word and when you do pass
it through so you're trying to you're
trying to see if the sentence is the
sentence I'm building is just based on
superficial like tone frequency
properties or is there actually
embedding some form of context doesn't
make sense or yeah so the next
topic is rather the probe is like the
context slice word embeddings which
seems to be hip and happening phrase
right now with like Burt and open yeah
so reiterating the same idea about a
probe it's just that so when I say
contextualize word embeddings they're
very different from say glove embedding
because in glove it would be like one
vector for one word but context lies
world and buildings is is when you do
parse a sentence you get like a word
embedding for every token based on the
context in which it in of that sense so
the idea is the same that if you have a
simple model which is trained to predict
like some sort of linguistic information
and this is a simple model then you can
infer that this information is actually
encoded in these word M buildings and
not really a property of this probing
architecture so some of the tasks you
can do for a word level embedding is
whether it has syntactic information
again like the part of speech the named
entity recognition given to tokens
whether you can actually get like the
dependencies between these tokens the
constituency labeling meaning they given
a sentence you want to induce like a
free structure on it so whether you can
identify a span of tokens as a verb
trace or a noun phrase semantic
information is basically anything you
can get from word net like what about
the the semantic role entailment
concreteness the koreff sentiment
relation extraction then the next sort
of thing you can probe for is like local
and long-range dependencies like if if
you were to take the task of dependency
labeling given two tokens which are like
two words apart and given two tokens
which are like ten words apart can you
still identify the dependencies then
that would be like a fine-grained
experiment to check whether like
long-range dependencies are actually
encoded in these contextualize word
embeddings I guess so most of my talk
was more about like
word embeddings probing them sent in
somebody's and probing them but this is
something which needs to be applied or
can be applied to any of the any of the
NLP TAS like I guess coming back to the
word representations you're trying to
see what sort of information is encoded
in these readings but another space is
what sort of information is not you're
trying to analyze like what sort of
information does it encode more is it
syntactic or semantic if it was language
modeling you can have different
objectives so language modeling but it's
interesting to see how if you were to
encode a sentence using a language model
how does that representation vary with a
different objective then you're so given
a language okay if I were to take an LS
TM as a language model and then I had a
bunch of layers in my illicium would
each of these layers encode the same
sort of information or different
information how do I effectively
transfer this sort of information from
my encoder to my downstream to us so
like there's this notion of lower layers
encoding more syntactic information and
higher layers encoding more semantic
information there's a there's also this
paper which talks about you want to do
like okay so Elmo embeddings
has a bunch of layers and the same sort
of norm follows there that the lower
levels are more syntactic and the higher
levels are semantic but effectively if
you want to improve on downstream tasks
if you want to use them as out of the
box then a weighted average of these
embeddings would be a nicer way than
just using one of the layers in
buildings so probing what layer encodes
what sort of information and I think
this is interesting
so if you were doing a task of say
machine translation then you can see how
you seek to seek model objectives can be
changed and how this normal encoder
would different properties based on the
objectives and I guess even just not
like even not even linguistic properties
but any if
if you're training like a deep neural
architecture sure bigger seems to be
better but you need to you need to have
interpretable models you need to
understand why models are doing the way
they are and this is a good place to
start off with by seeing what sort of
linguistic information do they capture
is it just based on huge amounts of data
or is it some inherent property of the
architecture so I guess I just want to
finish off by saying there's a lot of
work which can is being done and can be
done in this whole probing style
architecture because it'll be a
trade-off between what sort of tasks do
you want to probe what sort of
architecture do you want to do you want
to use and what sort of hypotheses do
you want to test on again as I mentioned
there's a lot of into like there's a lot
of need for interpretability of models
so this would be a nice place to explore
especially for your final projects to
see given that you've trained your model
to improve on some sort of evaluation
metric but does it does it do just the
objective it's being trained on or is it
doing something else as well then keep
probing yeah thank you
do you have any questions before yes
Aaron tradition like why would that be
so I haven't I haven't read up much
about it but it does so randomly
initialized neural networks do see do
serve as a strong baseline at least as
opposed to like a randomly initialize
vector like if I wanted to see and they
actually did for some of the probing to
us with regard to context lies word
embedding getting an embedding from this
randomly initialized encoder does on par
with like lava meetings which is very
interesting so it it as to why it is
happening that way I am not too sure
about it maybe maybe
maybe we can talk about it blow it off
for the nectar but yeah this is there
also research on like proving or
interpretability like non context
Florence embeddings
we just love you can't throw love for
what sort of information in the thing
and coded because if you look at no I
think there is some research on that
glove is inherently encoding some form
of frequency like based on whatever
corpus it is being trained on it does
inherently in cover like the unigram
probabilities like so frequency is one
of the properties which is encoded but I
I guess you can you could actually do
try out for different properties as well
this is answer your question type
information is that's encoded by piece
like more recent models so from my
understanding I think Elmo specifically
does include more syntactic information
than semantics like it does purely on
code reference resolution and in
semantic role labeling those sort of
stars but syntactic information it does
do better but again if you do look at
syntactic tasks I think like POS tagging
that is a relatively easier task so I
think even glove does well on that task
and so it's hard to say what
specifically is being encoded but this
is definitely an active field of
research at the moment from what I've
read syntactic information is something
which is encoded a lot and long-range
dependencies or something which is
encoded but semantic little bit any
other question
okay thank you
[Applause]